economics teaches humility because it
teaches us more about what we can't do
than what we can do
hi I'm Nick Gillespie with Reason TV and
we're talking with Pete bet key at
Freedom Fest in Las Vegas Nevada Pete
thanks for talking to me your latest
book you're an economist at George Mason
University or latest book living
economics yesterday today and tomorrow
you talk about the passion for economics
two words that don't normally come
together what is passion for economics
and why is it so important well I think
economics is a set of eyeglasses and
when you put those eyeglasses on you
bring the world into sharp relief so
it's not so much the ideological
position of it it's understanding it's a
way of thinking about the world it's a
methodology not a knitting ology right
it's and and but that methodology has
implications that are political in
nature when you follow persistently and
consistently all the way through on that
what is what is the most you know what's
the best elevator pitch case for
studying economics today not necessarily
as an academic but you know as a human
being well I think that the economic way
of thinking applies to every walk of
life and so it can make sense about a
lot of different issues from the way
that we get married the way we have kids
the way policies are determined by
government the way legal decisions are
made the way we behave in our religious
behavior so economics is not just about
the transferring of money it's about the
way that individuals act the incentives
that they face how they process those
incentives this is kind of a golden age
for economic thinking I mean you know
whether it's freakanomics or everywhere
everybody is talking in an economic way
in a way that in other years they might
have talked psychologically or
sociologically you know why why is
economics at the forefront right now
well I think there's two periods in our
lifetime where economics has really
moved to the forefront one of them is
when we were kids in late 1970s with the
stagflation and in the beginning of the
reagan you know sort of error and
economics was just on the tongue of
everyone and then there was some you
know outliers let's say the groups that
we like austrian economics public choice
and whatnot that could explain it and so
then that was kind of a
for that kind of thought and I would say
that that's also true since the
financial crisis that what you've had
again is everyone is affected by it you
know they hear it every day in their
news and what economic thinking does is
allow them to frame that sort of
discussion and then steer it in
directions of course in the current
discussion different than the time when
we were kids there's really a battle for
the interpretation of what went on the
Bush administration in no way was a free
market or less a fair I mean they
created regulations the whole types of
accounting regimes you name it they pump
the economy full of funny money you know
what is the Austrian understanding
because I mean this is you when you talk
about the Austrian school this is
something when I studied undergraduate
economics you know Hayek and Mises got
one paragraph in a 600 page textbook not
that way anymore what's going on that
Austrian the Austrian School of
Economics is moving to when you have a
financial crisis like this the Austrian
theory of the business cycle becomes
something that people try to think
through to make sense of what's going on
obviously there's a lot of contending
perspectives so I would say that
Austrian economics mixed with public
choice economics mixed with
institutional or property rights
economics forms the basis of this but
that people like Mises and Hayek were
the sort of first movers in developing
that kind of program in the modern times
talk about what what defines the
Austrian school in your mind as well as
idea you know that the unit of analysis
is the individual human actor the human
actor acting within constraints which in
some sense can be the lack of time
material research but also just the
rules that they in you know engage in
and that those rural environments are
going to dictate the flow of incentives
and information that people work with
and make in order sir what's the
Austrian reading that or your Austrian
reading of the financial crisis because
we hear from you know stimulatory ins
whether they're Keynesian or monitor as
saying what we need to do is have the
government flood the economy with more
money to restart the economy and it can
be through the Fed if you're a
monetarist or it can be through so I
think that what you see there is
Keynesianism but you have a waffling
between conservative Keynesianism or
liberal Keynesianism but let's go back
to the Austrians for a second
there I think that the one of the big
things with the audience to recognize
that the recession is the correction all
right in the previous malinvestments
that were generated by the you know
stimulus of the money right sort of
pushing down easy credit and
manipulation of money and credit led to
malinvestments so what you have is okay
why did those malinvestments take place
in a particular industry so you have to
have the malinvestment or excuse me the
manipulation of money credit then
combined with various different rules
and regulations which meant that housing
was an attractive place to make those
investments in and so you have to look
at a like a perfect storm kind of thing
right so you have greenspan doing the
greenspan put you have you know various
different things from the community you
know reinvestment you know all these
kind of things pushing money in a
direction there you have fannie and
freddie you know going their direction
all of that going in one direction which
means that you get the housing bubble
and then of course the bust on the
housing bubble you'll relate to this is
like when I first went to buy a house it
was in the old days when you had to have
20% down the prudent rule was that you
wouldn't spend any more on a mortgage
than what you would have in one week's
of your gross pay right that was being
prudent and it you go forward 20 years
later and one of my graduate students
you know rolled three mortgages in to
buy a house basically almost zero money
down and it was you know and what
happened to banking during that time
well a whole boatload of policies were
passed that made it difficult for
bankers to scrutinize the investment
loans barney frank is really responsible
for a lot of that and so one of the
things that was funny about 2008 funny
and a bad sense is that barney frank who
used to accuse banks of engaging in
discriminatory lending now we're
accusing them of predatory lending for
lending to the very folks that he said
they needed to lend to otherwise they
were discriminatory lending and he
didn't get like lambasted first and so
the I mean you know the difference is a
kind of Keynesian or macro approach is
the government the government or rather
from an Austrian perspective the
government rigged markets the markets
collapse and then Keynesian say well we
need more government intervention the
Austrians say no you you know when you
leave
balloon it's gonna pop and you got a
circuit right now what's going on you
know Bernanke spending 85 billion a
month in the to keep long-term interest
rates low what's that done to mortgage
rates pushed them way down so in
Northern Virginia where we live one of
the things that we've seen is an
increase in the housing market and you
know going up but what's interesting is
that while the money is available the
banks are being more scrutinizing the
loans more so one of the things that
we've seen you know go look this up is
that you have a lot of contracts falling
through at the assessment stage which
never used to happen right the
assessment was always like you know
FADEC oh you know kind of completes the
what are the limits of those eyeglasses
those economic eyeglasses when you put
them on I'm mark used to rail against
how long home Oh Monica kind of mikus I
mean we do is is an economic worldview
is it is it sufficient to explain
everything or what are the limits to it
and are we getting hubristic and
thinking economics explains everything
well I think that the key issue isn't
hubris it's that what happens is that
economics teaches humility because it
teaches us more about what we can't do
than what we can do the the limit that I
would recognize is that it's easiest way
to put this is that economists cannot
tell you whether or not profits are
deserved or not but what economics can
do is tell you the answer the
consequences of your answer to that
question so there is a limit of
economics I can't tell you those
normative ideas but what I can tell you
is the consequences of your normative
you know position so I think that there
there is a point where economics
interacts with normative issues and
again we also have to recognize is that
a lot of things that I said about rules
rules are the framework within which
economic activity takes place well then
what justifies that framework well for
most economists we sort of treat that
framework as given and then analyze the
consequences but that framework for
example can be determined by natural law
for now or some other version I happen
to be a rule utilitarian so I like sort
of make those kind arguments the
connection between my economics and my
morality is much tighter than a lot of
other people but you think a lot of
great classical liberals Adam Smith is a
natural law person and then you you know
and and that's where economics economics
isn't natural
economics comes in after the natural law
sets the framework
I want to thank Pete Becky at George
Mason University and the author most
recently of living economics author of
the forthcoming book tentatively titled
don't panic always good advice
Pete Becky thanks for talking to Reason
TV thanks a lot Nick I appreciate it